we have the release of infringed you
guys got to check it out before we get
started head over to
timcast.net film infringed is now
available it's been up since this
morning become a member to watch the
full length documentary share with your
friends we are doing a massive marketing
campaign behind this because it is not
just about the excellent work advocating
for our right to keep and bear arms
defend ourselves and the Practical issue
of how it's important if we want to
protect ourselves it's also about just
helping build that culture and I think
you know we're going to do a massive ad
campaign because the very least we're
going to get those commercials up across
YouTube and other platforms advocating
for your right to keep in be arms so if
you like the work that we're doing if
you watch the documentary already
already and you love it stay as a member
upgrade your membership and share with
your friends and if you haven't you
really do need to see it because it's
epic smash that like button subscribe to
this channel